the FBI's handling of the Hillary
Clinton email investigation is
increasingly looking corrupt hate to say
that but that's where the evidence is
showing us newly released text messages
sent between agents Peter Strock and
Lisa page who are dating one another
suggested the bureau felt quote pressure
to wrap up that investigation and
exonerate Hillary Clinton even before
they had interviewed her we could learn
more but the FBI says it has lost
thousands of messages text messages sent
between Strachan page publican senator
ron johnson represents wisconsin he
chairs the homeland security committees
one of the reasons we know any of this
in the first place he joins us tonight
senator thanks coming up no Tucker
so you remember of course when the
Attorney General Loretta Lynch said that
she would accept whatever the FBI's
recommendation was in the Hillary
Clinton investigation now it looks from
these texts that she had already decided
to exonerate Hillary Clinton well she
already knew that Comey was gonna
recommend exoneration so how is that I
mean that strikes me is the definition
of corruption am I missing something
no not at all you know what's making a
lot of news is the the five months of
missing text message yes which will
continue to to investigate ourselves but
I mean the fact that Loretta Lynch knew
before she made the big announcement
that oh you know because of potential
conflicts of interest meeting Bill
Clinton I'm going to let James Comey
decide that you know combined with all
the editing of that memo that was
started there was you know the
production that thing began two months
before they actually interviewed
Secretary Clinton that's a little bit of
a problem no there's so many things that
indicate a deep-seated corruption at the
highest levels of the FBI now again I
gotta say that the vast majority of FBI
folks are high integrity in there
they're risking their lives to keep us
safe but at the upper level but we're
starting to uncover is just a level of
corruption that needs further
investigation
so Lisa page FBI employees says Loretta
Lynch knows no charges will be brought
against Hillary Clinton wouldn't it be
worth speaking to former agent page or I
guess agent page I believe so at the
right point in time we want to make sure
we're going to try and recover those
five months worth of email tests or
texts
that's in a pretty crucial time between
December of 2016 in May a lot was going
down in terms of the FBI investigation
under the current administration so
they're just lost somehow they're
blaming the technology company
how often are people's tax liens just
lost by the government I mean text text
no the government money they don't sort
of leave all the paperwork for that if
somehow they lost this if we lose them
we got we're in big trouble
exactly okay we better get a good a tax
attorney or just a good attorney in some
way shape or form they're not very
forgiving if we lose evidence when they
lose it is just kind of technology blip
here you know don't worry about it
what we're gonna worry about we're gonna
keep digging so the idea is that they
had these texts in their possession and
then they lost them somehow
well they were supposed to be preserved
they're saying they didn't preserve them
but the good news is let's face it in
today's technology texts go up to some
server some cloud they're probably
stored somewhere which is why we'll
probably be releasing or we're gonna be
certainly looking at the president
record preservation record dead letters
to some of these technology companies
would it be possible to subpoena that
the cell phones how much they're written
probably have to do that yet right now
we're just gonna make sure they preserve
the evidence and then we will ask for
the information and just in this thing I
want it and hopefully we won't have to
subpoena yeah I hope you hopefully you
won't in the same fairness has the
former attorney general Lynch responded
to this in any way no she has not
responded you'd be really instant see
what she has to say it being saying see
what director Comey has to say as well
because I think he testified somewhat
it's somewhat variance to what these
texts reveal as well amazing
senator thank you very much for this
good night